hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm pretty
deep right we're gonna talk about the
trailer today for the Lazarus effect I
haven't seen the trailer yet
Olivia Wilde isn't it she's wild sort of
no I don't know Wow look at how
good-looking my girlfriend but I can't
say that when she's looking at me do you
see that stare
she is pretty I bet they don't look
scary her eyes get whiter and there's
really are you eyes bold that's they
become black scelera
it's scary
[Music]
this whole process started with the
Lazarus serum the goal here is simple to
bring someone back from the dead you're
playing God with a bunch of dead animals
if we're gonna be asking big questions
to be ready that's too much
[Music]
[Music]
okay you just went through a traumatic
experience they mutilate your body here
it's not solely in there they went
somewhere that was a dream
[Music]
Zoe we hope you like a whole bunch of
different horror films all together yeah
it's like Holloman Cujo Cujo and what
was I think you carry a little bit of
even does not work film but
transcendence the same thing happens
Johnny Depp's character is dying and she
hooks his mind up to a computer but he
becomes like something so powerful they
have to stop and like Holloman in the
sense or like of how you know they were
doing a science experiment
yeah person and Cujo because there's an
evil [ __ ] don't I was actually
digging the film up until the actual
horror start happening I was like what
what just happened like this doesn't
even make sense to me I get it if she's
like a serial killer but to have like
weird superpowers I don't know what's
going on reading his mind the glass is
breaking and she's crushes that guy
that's not a thing I'm carry telekinesis
telekinesis telepathic she's both yeah
she's both she's um Alakazam and I
forgot the first Pokemon anyway did you
fart no oh you did yeah somebody was
coming from the way it was starting off
it was like this is an interesting plot
like it seems like it's a horror film
and especially when there were like the
producers of all the [ __ ] horror
films that have been successful lately I
was like on board for it I was
interested to see like who like this
could have been an interesting like
scary character rather than like let's
just go for the Hollywood thrills again
and throw like jump scares in there and
stuff that's when I really started
losing my interest I was like I would
have my father seeing someone like
really deteriorate into something else
you know like yeah and then her becoming
scary like is that first I was watching
it and I'm like this will be the role
that if Olivia Wilde is great and it
could help really help redefine our
career because a lot of people know who
Olivia Wilde is now but if she's able to
actually make us be scared of her then
that's that's like oh we're not thinking
of Olivia Wilde anymore we're actually
scared of this character right but I
stopped being scared when they were
trying to scare us so I think they took
the creepy out by putting it so much on
the nose yeah I definitely agree with
that too because I think that you have
to when you're making films give your
audience a little bit of credit course
if you put it like right in your face
like hey this is where you're supposed
to be scared I'm gonna turn up the music
and yeah BAM like we just saw horse
trailer for indie flick after watching
an indie flick horde that'll that people
seem to be diggin and then I we tweet i
watch this we can watch this one there
is like studios stuff to it like it's
this it distracts me
it's formulaic scene the producers input
on it you know like there could be good
producers and bad producers but those
like studio producers who I hope to one
day work with by the way just as far as
storyline goes you're seeing it's just a
little bit formula yeah I really think
it could have been a really tension
filled thriller first it's like sci-fi
horror then it's paranormal horror yes
and I'm like too much for me did you
ever read Pet Sematary kind of reminded
me of that - I know he said Cujo and
there's a scene in Cujo I like a my feel
like I've seen it like when they're in
that car mm-hmm and the dogs like
attacking them and they're like no
that's how I felt when the dog was
standing on top of her that was scary I
was like other because you dog if a dog
is feeling that it's gonna attack you
yeah that part was creepy yeah I'm sure
and they were together and drinking
buddies Olivia Wilde and I forgot the
other guy's name but they did the movie
drink
any film called drinking buddies that's
why I don't know it yeah who the [ __ ]
cares about it
did you see 500 a in the summer yeah
it's kind of along the same vein as as
far as tonality goes I just want to
clarify um I do like independent films
mmm meat you know I think he likes in
the pinnacle yeah
Reservoir Dogs El Mariachi do you see
chef Wes here oh did I see chef what
kind of a question is that
I know is Jon Favreau he directed and
wrote and starred in it and had Robert
Downey jr. at one point not that one no
Downey jr. makes an appearance in it
yeah he does oh he does Wow when I
didn't even see the movie anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects there's so
much [ __ ] on here you might even walk
away from the channel and you can check
out brandy prices channel she does a lot
of independent movie reviews go ahead
and suggest something to her because she
needs to know what's really out there I
do which is love there's love for you
out there
I need his love no no no no money is
probably the number one what then love
[ __ ] don't love a guy with no money
ain't that right baby right she ain't
here me that's why she's a great Randall
Justice Oh Oh too many jokes are
entering the head right now there you
can easily play with that name y'all
videos are funny no one yes y'all's
y'all's videos are funny my name is
Randall justice
I'm the deadliest mother [ __ ] in this
city and I [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz I got money and my pant hand
yeah I know I know what that is I
totally know what you're talking about
Oh Oh your pimp and paint pen oh yeah no
I have a pen pad yeah dad I don't use
anymore baby
so they
who is boss well occasionally you
Randall Justice is a pimp exactly save
me they're ready Raphael Akeno hey Ryan
just wondering but what's your ethnicity
lol hope this question is an offensive
just curious I could not be more
offended right now that is racist who
cares about my ethnicity if you have to
know I'm Italian and Filipino good mix
and like I tell people Italians have big
dicks Filipinos have small dicks I'm
just the right size that answers your
question that right baby
if your body locks I understand yes sir
yes yes and I get the reference now the
children's story yeah that's great I'm
glad you included that in my dick joke
thank you